Kristen is on the line to start us off
this hour in Ohio hi Kristin how are you
I'm good good how can I help my um my
husband I have started your plan about
seven months ago and in that time paid
off twenty three thousand dollars
great uh yeah so really happy really
excited about the plan so far we have
about 70 total family thousand total
from when we started and I read your
book and I read two of your books and
I'm I try to get my husband to read the
Total Money Makeover and he brought
about two chapters decided that I mean
what I was doing and just kind of lets
me run with the budget and just asks for
permission to spend on different item
but isn't really like it's not a
collaborative effort and how old are you
guys I'm I'm 28 my husband 32 I'm tell
you how long have you been married three
years what's your like window for a
little bit what's your husband doing
he's a deputy in the house in the house
of his group that he grew up in to his
mom take care of everything yeah yeah
yeah that's that's how he learned how to
do this right so he he she's I'm a
banker and that's not the point it's not
the point the point is when he know
where he learned how to be married was
watching his mom and dad and his mom did
all the money and his dad brought in the
bacon and was passive in the decisions
and that's that's the only training he's
had that makes sense yeah
by the way it's wrong but it's the only
training he's had okay and so here's how
we break it cuz your husband is a man of
honor
mm-hmm with what he does for a living
he's a person of honor
he's a person of dignity
he would never in a million years think
of burdening his wife he's not that guy
he just was shown the way he was grown
up that you know mom handles the money
dad brings in the bacon and so all you
have to do is there's just a little bit
of he just needs some new information
he's 32 years old he's a young dad a
young husband whatever right and so
here's how it sounds okay honey I need
you to be my man and let me explain to
you what that means that means I am NOT
carrying all the responsibilities of
this household on my shoulders by myself
I refuse to be your mommy I am NOT going
to tell you what to do like I'm your
mommy
I want you to walk beside me with me and
carry the weight of the decisions of
this household that's what a man does
and I'm not gonna I'm not gonna dull I'm
not gonna dole out money to you like you
are on an allowance and I'm your mommy
and I am and I make all the big
important decisions in this household
yeah I am NOT going to do that you and I
are going to work together on this and
you are gonna step up and walk beside me
and that's what a man of honor like you
are would do and he will do it once he
understands that last night we tried to
have that conversation and he said it
was putting too many hands in the honey
pot he's wrong I know telling me needs
to man up okay people that don't listen
I am America's trusted voice on money if
anybody could do this without their
spouse it would be me but guess what I
don't I don't and here's the other I do
it for - I mean Sharon is involved in
our major in our financial decisions and
all major decisions in our life I don't
do it by myself because I make better
decisions with my wife involved and when
she's involved in the decision if it
goes sideways I don't get an
i-told-you-so
okay so I have a secondary question then
do you think that it would be wise for
me to go ahead and spend the money to go
to an FPU class no unless your husband
will go no no I think you work he goes
with you that's fine and if he's
agreeing to participate in this process
that's fine but if you go over there
then you're just gonna become the mommy
and maybe you want to be a mommy I don't
know to your 32 year old little boy I
don't know but maybe he needs to be a
man too so I think he step up beside you
and you guys make these decisions he
needs to man up and he doesn't need to
be overbearing to you you don't need to
be overbearing to him we submit
ourselves one to another an act of unity
an act of love Sharon and I if we can't
come to a decision we just don't do the
thing we as an act of unity I don't go
do stuff I don't come home and buy some
expensive item she doesn't come home and
buy some expensive item I go look what I
did didn't this wonderful no we make
those decisions together now if I'm
buying a boat or something like that she
probably doesn't give a rip you know and
she just like well okay whatever I mean
she look at it but she's not all
concerned about something I might if
she's buying some Sharon thing whatever
that is and there's plenty of those
things but redecorating a room yeah
that's like a constant okay so if she's
doing that I don't give a rip but I'm
gonna be involved because I want to know
what it's gonna cost and you know we're
gonna actually use our brains and how we
do redecorate the room and I I'm not
gonna pick all the colors I don't give a
rip about that that's that's her thing
but but I'm but we're gonna make these
major life decisions together and
handling money on a monthly basis is one
of those and if you don't do that if you
drive off from that you're going to
suffer in not only your relationship but
you're going to suffer in your wealth
building high correlation very
statistically high correlation between
couples working together on their money
the ones that become wealthy very few
people drag a child bride or a child
husband along and become wealthy it's
dead weight and so instead we're walking
together we're working together we're
making wise decisions together it keeps
us from impulsing our butts off it keeps
us from making as many bad decisions
most bad decisions are made by just one
person almost all the decisions I've
made in my life that were absolutely
sucked I made those completely by myself
the Bible says who can find a virtuous
wife her worth is far above rubies the
heart of her husband safely trusts her
and he will have no lack of gain I had
to learn to involve my wife's input in
our stuff because I'm perfectly capable
of making decisions without anybody's
help but I often make wrong ones when I
do that good lesson for everybody out
there there's a high statistical
correlation on your ability to build
wealth and your ability to work together
as a couple
listen to that